Freunde der Sonne. Ich bin's wieder,
Mai, Eure Chemikerin des Vertrauens.
Heute ausnahmsweise
nicht mit einem Tee,
sondern mit einem Golden Latte.
Ein Kurkuma Latte.
Hmh.
Das Zeug ist nicht nur
100 % Instagramable,
sondern auch sehr gesund,
so heißt es.
Kurkuma, zu Deutsch Gelbwurz,
zählt zu den gesündesten Gewürzen
der Welt.
Das liegt daran,
dass in der exotischen Wurzel
mind. 90 unterschiedliche Wirkstoffe
enthalten sind.
Hast du Hautprobleme, Haarausfall
oder Probleme mit extra Pfunden...
Er hat mir einen 1-Kilo-Beutel
Kurkuma unter die Nase gehalten
und gemeint: "Trink das mal.
Ich hab gelesen, das ist gut."
Ich behaupte mal,
dass sie mich schon
vor Krankheiten bewahrt hat.
Kurkuma Video.
Kurkuma enthält ein Molekül
namens Curcumin.
Das ist übrigens auch verantwortlich
für die intensive gelbe Farbe,
aber nicht nur das.
Die Liste,
wogegen Curcumin helfen soll,
ist beeindruckend.
Wann immer ein "Wundermittel"
gegen eine ganze Liste
von Krankheiten wirken soll,
sollte direkt
das Bullshit-O-Meter ausschlagen.
Aber das Interessante
an Curcumin ist,
dass es unglaublich viele
wissenschaftliche Studien gibt,
auch klinische Studien
mit Menschen.
Und das ist eher untypisch für ein
klassisches Bullshit-Allheilmittel.
Deshalb, holt euch 'n Tee
oder ein Kurkuma Latte.
Macht es euch gemütlich,
wir schauen uns die Wissenschaft
hinter dem goldenen Zeug
etwas genauer an.
* Titelmusik *
Ihr werdet im Netz unzählige Artikel
finden über Curcumin.
Und dass es ein potenzieller
oder vielversprechender Wirkstoff
sein könnte
für verschiedene Krankheiten, aber
was heißt das überhaupt genau?
Um das zu verstehen,
müssen wir erst mal wissen,
wie neue Wirkstoffe
entdeckt oder identifiziert werden.
Ich hoffe, ihr habt es euch
gemütlich gemacht.
Das wird jetzt ein kleiner Ausflug,
aber glaubt mir, es lohnt sich.
Denn man hört ja ständig
von irgendwelchen neuen Therapien.
Was ich euch gleich erzähle,
wird euch noch oft helfen,
um solche Meldungen in Zukunft
besser einordnen zu können, also...
Um eine Krankheit zu bekämpfen,
muss ich sie erst mal verstehen.
Sagen wir, Biologen finden heraus,
dass eine bestimmte Krebsart
durch ein bestimmtes
mutiertes Protein verursacht wird.
Dafür gibt es Beispiele, d.h.
um diesen Krebs zu bekämpfen,
müssen wir
dieses mutierte Protein ausschalten.
Das Protein wird zum Target ernannt.
Also zum Ziel oder zur Zielscheibe.
Gesucht wird jetzt ein Wirkstoff,
der dieses Target abschießt,
also dieses Protein deaktiviert.
Dann geht die Suche los.
# Here check a ha, here check a ha
Screening bedeutet einfach
das Testen sehr vieler Substanzen.
D.h. man nimmt 'n Haufen Moleküle.
Das können natürliche sein
oder welche,
die man im Labor hergestellt hat,
und schmeißt die jeweils
auf das Target drauf
und schaut, ob was dabei ist,
was das Protein ausschaltet.
Beachten muss man,
was wir hier brauchen,
ist eine spezifische Wirkung.
Beispiel:
Durch Erhitzen kann ich
jedes Protein kaputtmachen.
Deswegen ist Hitze
noch lange kein Antikrebsmittel.
Denn Hitze
macht jedes Protein kaputt
und nicht nur gezielt
das mutierte Krebsprotein.
Und genauso gibt es auch Moleküle,
die alle möglichen Effekte haben.
Die binden vielleicht bisschen
an das mutierte Protein,
aber dafür auch
an 100 andere Proteine,
und gehen chemische Reaktionen ein
in der Zelle
mit Sachen,
die ihnen über den Weg laufen.
Das brauchen wir nicht.
Wir brauchen
einen spezifischen Wirkstoff,
der gezielt das mutierte Protein
ausschaltet,
alles andere aber
in Ruhe lässt.
Zum Glück können immer mehr Proteine
gezielt ausgeschaltet werden.
Denn der Schalter ist gewissermaßen
in die Proteinstruktur
eingebaut.
Eine Proteinstruktur
ist wie ein großes 3D-Origami.
Und viele Proteine haben ein Loch
oder eine Tasche.
Enzyme z.B. sind Proteine
mit so 'ner Tasche.
Und die Tasche
is where the magic happens.
In diese Tasche
passen nur bestimmte Moleküle.
Manchmal vergleicht man das System
mit dem Schlüssel-Schloss-Prinzip.
Und dieses Schlüsselloch,
also diese Proteintasche,
die gilt es anzugreifen.
Wenn jetzt ein Wirkstoffmolekül
perfekt in diese Tasche passt,
kann es quasi andocken
und die Tasche blockieren.
Damit kann das Enzym
seine Aktivität nicht mehr ausführen
und ist damit ausgeschaltet.
So, weil man sich nur bedingt
theoretisch herleiten kann,
wie so ein superpassendes Molekül
aussehen könnte,
verfährt man bei 'nem Screening
nach dem Prinzip
"Probieren über Studieren".
Man probiert einfach
ganz viele Moleküle aus,
das können eine Million sein
oder mehr.
Jetzt denkt man,
wie soll das funktionieren?
'ne Million Reagenzgläser oder was?
Gewissermaßen schon,
nur in kleinem Maßstab.
Man nimmt da z.B.
solche 384 Well Plates.
Die sind in Wirklichkeit
ungefähr so groß
und haben dann in dem Fall
384 so kleine Reagenzgefäße da drin.
Das wär für ein klassisches
Highthroughput Screening.
Hochdurchsatz-Screening. Da hat man
diese Plates und Pipetierroboter.
Und die kombinieren
in den kleinen Reagenzgefäßen
das mutierte Protein
mit einer der Million Substanzen
und hoffen, dass
ein potenzieller Wirkstoff dabei ist.
Man screent das Ganze durch,
filtert das Ganze runter
und geht dann am Ende mit den
positiven Hits in die nächste Runde.
Man nimmt dann z.B. Krebszellen
und schaut,
ob man mit Hilfe der Hit-Moleküle
Wachstum stoppen kann
oder ob in den Zellen
das Enzym noch aktiv ist,
wenn man das Hit-Molekül
hinzugibt.
Chemiker können dann die guten
Moleküle noch weiter optimieren.
Die bauen dann hier ein paar Atome
ein und nehmen da ein paar raus,
geben die den Biologen,
die testen sie in den Zellen usw.
Und nach vielen, vielen Jahren Arbeit
schafft man es vielleicht
zum nächsten Schritt.
In der Regel
testet man zunächst an Mäusen.
Die haben dann
diesen bestimmten Krebs.
Man versucht, sie zu heilen
und schaut nach Nebenwirkungen.
Und wenn am Ende immer noch
Moleküle im Rennen sind,
die gut aussehen, dann kann man
in die klinischen Studien.
Puh, so kann eine Wirkstoffsuche
allgemein aussehen.
Die Frage ist jetzt, wo genau
ist der aktuelle Forschungsstand
bei Curcumin?
Oder sollte ich sagen...
Curcumin hat sich bisher
in unzähligen Screenings
als positiver Hit
bemerkbar gemacht.
Und zwar für verschiedene Targets.
D.h. ja, die Liste,
die ich am Anfang aufgezählt habe,
die wurde nicht von irgendwelchen
"Internetexperten" erfunden,
sondern beruht tatsächlich
auf wissenschaftlichen Studien.
Auch bei etlichen Zellstudien
und auch bei einigen Mausstudien
gab es positive Ergebnisse.
Aber seltsamerweise
gibt es bisher
keine belastbaren Daten
aus klinischen Studien
mit Menschen.
Wenn ihr das Video
über Handystrahlung gesehen habt,
wisst ihr, dass randomisierte
kontrollierte Studien
der Goldstandard
der Studien sind.
Ha, Goldstandard!
Doch keine dieser
sorgfältig durchgeführten Studien
zeigt irgendwelche Benefits
von Curcumin.
Was ist da los?
Es ist nicht alles Gold, was...
gold aussieht... Nee, was?
Bei aller Sorgfalt
in der Wirkstoffentwicklung
gibt es fiese Fallen.
Z.B. Moleküle,
die man als "chemical con artists",
also chemische Hochstapler
oder Trickbetrüger bezeichnen kann.
Fiese Gesellen, die uns
auf die falsche Fährte locken.
Aber um das zu verstehen, müssen wir
tiefer in die Chemie eintauchen.
# Advanced Chemistry
Entschuldigung.
Wir sprachen über das
gezielte Ausschalten von Proteinen,
z.B. durch Blockieren der Tasche.
Aber woher wissen wir,
dass das passiert?
Man kann ja Proteine und Moleküle
nicht mit bloßem Auge sehen.
Und es gibt auch kein Mikroskop,
das gut genug wäre,
um zu schauen,
ob das Molekül in die Tasche geht.
Aber Wissenschaftler
sind gewitzte Menschen
und haben verschiedene Tests
entwickelt.
Assays nennt man diese Tests auch
und damit
kann man indirekt "sehen",
ob es geklappt hat.
Man gibt z.B. einen Farbstoff hinzu,
einen Fluoreszenzfarbstoff,
der nur dann aktiv wird,
wenn das Protein deaktiviert wird.
D.h. wenn ich mein Testmolekül
hinzugebe und die Lösung wird grün,
habe ich einen positiven Hit.
Oder ich schaue, ob Krebszellen
mein Testmolekül überleben.
Wenn sie sterben,
ist es auch ein positives Ergebnis.
Es gibt viele verschiedene Assays,
und man muss immer verschiedene
durchführen, um sicherzugehen.
Aber jetzt gibt es die hier:
Moleküle,
die zwar positive Hits generieren,
die aber
falsch-positiv sind.
Z.B. die Lösung wird grün,
aber nicht,
weil mein Protein
ausgeschaltet wurde,
sondern weil das Molekül direkt
den Farbstoff angeschaltet hat.
Oder die Krebszelle stirbt,
aber nicht,
weil das Molekül
mit dem Protein interagiert hat,
sondern weil das Molekül
generell Zellwände zerstört.
Und manche Moleküle
sind dazu in der Lage,
in vielen verschiedenen Assays
positive Hits zu generieren.
Einfach nur, weil sie chemisch
sehr vielfältig aktiv sind.
Chemisch promiskuös,
könnte man quasi sagen.
Chemische Hochstapler.
Resveratrol ist z.B. so ein Molekül,
das in allen möglichen Assays
falsch-positive Hits aufzeigt.
Resveratrol ist das Molekül,
das Rotwein so gesund machen soll.
Ob Rotwein gesund ist oder nicht,
dazu haben wir schon dieses Video.
Weil Resveratrol
und andere "Hochstaplermoleküle"
den Wirkstoffentwicklern
das Leben so schwer machen,
haben sie sogar
einen Extranamen bekommen, nämlich:
Weil sie auch einfach painful sind,
wenn man aufgrund falscher Hits
Zeit, Geld und Arbeit verschwendet,
um einer falschen Fährte
nachzuforschen.
Ja, und jetzt ratet mal,
was mit Curcumin ist.
Curcumin ist ein Pain,
wie er im Buche steht.
In diesem Artikel,
der 2014 in "Nature" erschien,
wird Curcumin aufgelistet
unter den worst offenders,
den schlimmsten Übeltätern.
Seine chemische Promiskuität
befähigt es dazu, sich durch viele
gängige Assays durchzucheaten.
Es ist generell
nicht besonders stabil.
Was chemisch heißt,
es ist reaktiv.
Es gibt allein vier gängige Wege,
über die Curcumin
leicht zerfallen kann.
Und die Folgeprodukte können wieder
chemische Reaktionen eingehen.
Das erklärt auch, warum Curcumin
in den Vortests so erfolgreich ist,
aber bei vielen Tierversuchen
und spätestens
in den klinischen Versuchen versagt.
Aber wenn Curcumin so reaktiv ist
und es mit jedem treibt,
ist es dann nicht auch giftig?
Eine reaktive Substanz
ist potenziell schädlich.
Weil sie im Körper
mit allem reagieren
und Schäden hinterlassen kann.
Bei Curcumin
und v.a. Kurkuma, dem Gewürz,
ist das aber nicht der Fall.
Zumindest erst ab Konzentrationen,
die wir praktisch nicht
zu uns nehmen können.
Erstens enthält
das Gewürz Kurkuma
nur 1 bis 6 % Curcumin.
Aber effektiv
ist es noch viel weniger,
denn die sogenannte
Bioverfügbarkeit,
also was wirklich im Körper ankommt,
beträgt gerade mal 1 %.
Das meiste wird...
Ja, wie soll ich sagen?
...ausgekackt.
Da kann man sich immerhin
so was sparen.
Das ist also beruhigend
für irgendwelche negativen Effekte,
aber natürlich gilt das auch
für positive Effekte.
Selbst wenn es positive Effekte gäbe,
ist die Bioverfügbarkeit von Curcumin
ohnehin so lausig,
dass davon
nicht wirklich viel ankommt.
Man muss ergänzen, man kann
die Bioverfügbarkeit erhöhen,
indem man es mit etwas Pfeffer
kombiniert, wegen Piperin.
Aber es gibt noch 'n Problem.
Curcumin baut sich
viel zu schnell ab,
weil es eben
nicht besonders stabil ist.
Wirkstoffe, die auch eine Zeit
im Körper wirken sollen,
haben meist eine Halbwertzeit
von mehreren Stunden.
Bei Curcumin
sind es nur wenige Minuten.
Bleibt nur noch die Frage,
wenn man das alles weiß,
wieso gibt es dann immer noch
so viele Studien? Gute Frage!
Für den Medizinalchemiker
Jonathan Baell
ist die Veröffentlichung
positiver Ergebnisse
von reaktionsfreudigen
Hochstaplermolekülen vergleichbar mit
Müll auf die Straße werfen.
Er spricht von pollution,
also Verschmutzung
der wissenschaftlichen
Veröffentlichungen.
Das sind jetzt sehr harte Worte.
Ich würde es so einordnen.
Die Forschung an Curcumin
ist trotz der Studienfülle
noch sehr am Anfang.
Und obwohl es Paper gibt,
die vor Pains warnen
und auch explizit vor Curcumin,
steht denen so eine Riesenmenge
an positiven Papern dazu gegenüber,
die so ein falsches Ungleichgewicht
erzeugen.
Hinzukommt, das muss man auch sagen,
dass manche Wissenschaftler
froh sind,
wenn sie positive Hits
vorzuweisen haben
weil sie leider unter einem
unglaublichen Druck stehen
positive Ergebnisse
zu veröffentlichen.
Aber das Problem haben wir
in diesem Video schon mal besprochen.
Für unseren Alltag heißt das:
Kurkuma Latte sieht super aus.
Aber die Zuschreibung "Wundermittel",
das kommt eher aus Tradition
und nicht aus der Wissenschaft.
Und ich will den ganzen YouTubern
und Influencern, die darauf schwören,
nicht vorwerfen,
dass sie lügen, um Gottes willen!
Aber wohltuende Erlebnisse
von Einzelpersonen
sind kein Wirksamkeitsbeleg.
Wenn es mir nach diesem Latte
blendend geht,
kann das an dem Latte liegen,
aber auch an sonst was.
Wissenschaftlich
ist bisher leider nichts belegt
und deswegen auch not approved.
Wenn ihr Vorschläge habt, was ich
noch wissenschaftlich prüfen kann,
schreibt es in die Kommentare.
Bis nächste Woche.
Bleibt sicher.
Ich habs sofort
in die Waschmaschine getan, aber...
Kurkuma forever, I guess.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2019)